in about one month's time millions of
high school students will be taking the
sat one of two standardized tests that
colleges once required for admission but
after the college board recently
announced major changes to the s.a.t
making it shorter in length and all
digital the question now is how relevant
are standardized tests and what value do
they offer especially as universities
try to attract more diverse applicants
joining us to discuss this and more is
ben paris an elite test prep tutor who
has worked with students for more than
two decades ben good to see you
the college board made these massive
changes which take effect in the next
two years is this all too little too
late do they keep the sat relevant and
useful to the admissions process
well the sat can't really change what it
fundamentally does the essence of a
standardized test is that it has to
provide a pretty much the same result
over time they're going to measure the
same skills in the same ways and
these changes in some ways are going to
make it easier on the test takers you're
going to get a shorter test they're
going to have a graphing calculator for
everyone
but the the key issues around testing
and inequality are going to remain the
question is what value do these tests
have and i would argue that if you
include standardized tests you have in
general a more humane process than if
you have more of a focus on grades
wait you argue that keeping the test you
have a more humane
process
explain that to me because i mean you
are a test prep tutor so obviously your
livelihood depends on kids paying you to
help them prepare for an exam so of
course there's financial self-interest
but what is the moral argument for
keeping and preserving these tests
especially when there is so much
criticism that they exacerbate
inequality
right so i will i will gladly admit my
bias here although don't worry about me
no matter how these things play out i'll
be fine
but you have to look at what happens if
you eliminate standardized tests right
now
you've got in elite institutions more
than half the applicants have a averages
and so whereas it used to be the case
that good grades would get you in now
it's the case that bad grades are
keeping you out so we're forcing
everybody to take these advanced courses
that
may not be interesting to them uh have
nothing to do with their career goals
and so if you remove the test then
you're robbing people of an opportunity
to show that they have the skills that
um that the colleges are looking for now
i think these tests can be better i'd
call the s.a.t a blight on education
uh we can we can make much better tests
but if we remove them entirely then we
put a lot of focus on other factors that
may make the overall experience worse we
have millions of people taking courses
that they don't want to take that have
nothing to do with their career goals
and that makes the situation worth a
quick test that you could prepare for in
a month or so would be more humane than
dragging everyone through courses that
they don't want to take what about the
idea that standardized tests in general
are exacerbating and worsening
magnifying inequality
yeah well we have tremendous inequality
in our society and this comes from
before people are born all the way
through the time that they take
standardized tests we're talking about
exposure to teratogens we're talking
about prenatal care there are all kinds
of inequalities that that we have to
solve but it would be a miracle if tests
like the sat made all these things go
away around testing time so by the time
people take these tests
you wouldn't expect the results to be
absolutely the same for every single
group because of the inequality that
came in before they got there so while
um while there are aspects in which
standardized testing can magnify
inequality
in general the uh there's a lot of good
low-cost uh test prep out there
and um a lot of the a lot of the
advantages um of a privilege experience
are baked in long before you get to the
test okay so it sounds like you see
value in standardized testing in general
maybe not the sat because it's ha it has
its particular flaws why isn't there as
much of a debate over say the lsat or
the gre or the gmats do those exams do a
better job of
measuring applicants knowledge and
assessing their their preparation their
their ability to do the work that's
required of them
yes um so in general the s the lsat and
the gmat are much better tests none of
these tests really measure knowledge
they really measure skills
the lsat and the gmat are much more
defensible and the gre doesn't get the
same level of criticism because it's
typically not as high stakes a test
the sat is a ruthless test of compliance
you have to get rid of almost
any imagination you have to read things
in the most literal um petty
detail-oriented way that's the kind of
skill that gets rewarded so the
questions are hard but they're hard in a
way that rewards a particular kind of
test taker
and that's not necessarily the person
who is going to be most successful in
college and they're about and thereafter
still it does measure a lot of skills
that are relevant and a better test
would cover more of those relevant
skills but the sap can add something
okay so what would
if you could design a new standardized
test what would it look like
so i think it's important to measure
higher order thinking skills and one of
the key things that you want to do is
you want to measure skills that aren't
necessarily covered in grades the sat is
designed to cover the curriculum
concepts that people hit in high school
but but you already have their grades so
why not test something different let's
get at critical thinking skills um in
the past vocabulary based questions
while they were politically unpopular
were some of the best questions for
distinguishing who was going to be
who's going to be successful in college
because the only way to really be ready
for those questions was to have actually
done a lot of reading
i'd like to see a proctored writing
sample
even unscored just to get some kind of
indication of the applicant's writing
because think about how much you can
learn
about someone's academic skill just by
reading one paragraph that they wrote
um i didn't i also like to see two tiers
of math
we are forcing everyone to go through
really advanced math that they are not
interested in and will never use and but
some people will be interested in that
kind of thing so let's have two tiers of
math let's have the basics everyone
needs to know about percentages ratios
rates and those kinds of things right
and then have a higher level of math for
the more advanced stuff yeah i like i
like keeping it to the percent in ratio
and all that um
removing the test requirement as we've
seen over the last two years has really
opened the floodgates to greater numbers
of college applicants from
many more diverse backgrounds and that's
pretty much what colleges wanted all
along they're kind of looking for ways
to broaden their applicant pool
what is the downside for them i mean i'm
looking at how harvard saw the number of
applicants increase by 42 and overall
there was an 11 increase in common
applications and submissions uh year
over year
what's the downside for colleges to
remove the test requirement
well if you really care about dealing
with inequality then you have to deal
with the data you can't just ignore the
data there are differences in
performances and if you just and you
just pretend those things aren't there
then you've got a problem and then the
other thing i would say is that if you
get rid of those tests and you're
depriving people who didn't succeed in
the compliance punishment world of high
school you're depriving those people of
a chance to succeed and you're putting
all of this emphasis
on grades forcing people to take
calculus chemistry biology ap ap history
all of these things that they may not be
interested in taking and the human toll
of millions of people taking courses
that they don't that they're not
interested in is something that has
moral significance
so maybe worse to have to take all these
ap classes that you don't want to take
than it is to prepare for something like
a standardized test so
given that this is all in flux these
changes that we just discussed won't
take place for another two to three
years what is your advice to high school
students now who need to navigate this
period of transition because
there is going to be it doesn't feel
like this is the end of the the way here
we're going to have more changes coming
up
absolutely um as long as you're applying
to schools that will accept sap or act
scores um even if it's optional then you
owe it to yourself to at least try to
find out how you would do on them will
it be an advantage for you now if you
take a practice test in both of them and
it's just a total wreck and you and you
don't have a realistic opportunity to do
better then you might as well just go
test optional but if you do very well on
them or you could do very well
then investing in test preparation could
be well worth it for you whether you go
to someone like me or whether you study
on your own okay project out for us what
you see happening in the long term here
because this seems an area that is ripe
for disruption where is it going to come
from because it's not going to be from
the college board which has shown us
that it's just going to make tweaks and
changes around the margins
yes so we've got a situation where lots
of people are unhappy with these tests
um they're not giving people the kind of
information that they want and this is
and you have millions of people taking
courses that they don't want to take
this is not sustainable
in the long run i hope and predict that
there are going to be other kinds of
tests that are going to pop up that are
going to allow people to for a fee
get some kind of certification that they
have a particular kind of skill we're
probably going to see this first in the
realm of pre-employment testing before
we see it for college admission so what
you're going to see more and more is
you're going to be able to take tests
that are going to allow you to
distinguish yourself from the huge pool
of applicants any kind of open
application right now has way too many
applicants uh and employers don't treat
the college credential all that
seriously they're looking for something
else that tells that tells them that
you're ready to do the job
you